TODAY'S HEARING OF ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION WE ARE CONTINUING TO
PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON WE ARE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT FACEMASK BE WORN AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM ARE AT THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL. PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE HEARING ROOM. FOR
DIALING WITNESSES WE ARE ALSO
WE ALSO BE USING A MODERATE
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AS WE HAVE
ONLY A LIMITED NUMBER OF BILLS
TODAY ON THE AGENDA. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN. PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
EIGHT MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO
HELP YOU. I ALSO KNOW THAT WE
ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION. LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. NOW LET'S GO OVER A
FEW MORE ADDITIONAL
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS. FOR
THE BILLS BEING TAKEN UP TODAY
WE WILL TAKE NO MORE THAN TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR WITH CONCERNS.
DIDN'T WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH OF RATHER
TESTIMONY. ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY. FILE
ITEM EIGHT SB EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE. BY THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR FROM
TODAY'S HEARING. FINALLY WE
HAVE FOR BILLS ON OUR PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR THESE BILLS
ARE FILE ITEM TWO SB THREE
FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR CAFIERO
FILE ITEM FOR S. B. TWO
NINETEEN BY CENTER MCGUIRE.
FILE ITEM SIX SB FOUR NINETY
ONE BY SENATOR NIELSEN AND FILE
ITEM SEVEN SB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
BY THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE. WE ARE CLOSING IN
ON A QUORUM. HELLO AUTHOR.
OKAY
ALREADY DID THAT MISSILE
INCOMING CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
WE HAVE A QUORUM. BURKE. WHEN
GREG GRAYSON. LIVING THERE
MAYES. MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS
WORK HERE RIVAS THEY ARE TWELVE
HERE. WE HAVE A QUORUM MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU SO WHY DON'T
WE JUST GO TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SINCE WE'RE WAITING
FOR AUTHORS. THE MOVE. WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND- IF I
WOULD CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THAT YOU
WANTED. THE ONLY CONTENT
ALLOWED GO BACK AND READ THEM
FILE ITEM TO FILE ITEM FOUR SIX
AND SEVEN. I THINK WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND AYE GRAYSON
SECOND VICE THE RKO ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR BURKE. BURKE
AYE WENT. GREAT MASON BY
GRAYSON ONLINE LIVING. LEVINE
AYE MAYES MAYES I'M MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
CLERK. I RIVAS SARATOGA
SARATOGA THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS PASSED. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS PASSED AS WE ARE NOW JUST
WAITING FOR OFFICE.
YEAH THAT'S
RIGHT. LEARN ABOUT. YEAH RIGHT
OKAY CALL.
NINE THANK.
YEAH.
YEAH. YEAH-
MIDDLE. ARAFAT THE
HOBBIT. YEAH THE WAY. YEAH.
WELCOME SENATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR- FILE ITEM TWO
IS ON CONSENT AND THAT'S
FINISHED A FILE ITEM THREE SB
THREE NINETY FIVE YOU WANT TO
START WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT SB THREE NINETY
FIVE A TERRIBLE EPIDEMIC HAS
PLAGUED OUR YOUTH IN OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR SEVERAL YEARS
AND IF LEFT UNCHECKED WILL
CONTINUE TO DO HARM FOR MANY
GENERATIONS TO COME. E.
CIGARETTES CONTAIN A HARMFUL
COMBINATION OF NICOTINE
FLAVORING AND OTHER CHEMICALS
ADDITIVES AND ALL THERE THOUGH
THEY ARE CURRENTLY TAXED AS
OTHER TOBACCO PRODUCTS THE TAX
RATE IS MUCH LOWER THAN THAT OF
TRADITIONAL CIGARETTES THEREBY
CONTRIBUTING TO THE GROWING
DISPARITY BETWEEN THESE
PRODUCTS AND UNDERMINING
EFFORTS TO CURB VAPING THIS
MEASURE SEEKS TO CREATE PARITY
BETWEEN THESE PRODUCTS BEIPING
HAS BECOME INCREASINGLY POPULAR
DESPITE THE HIGH RISK OF
ADVERSE HEALTH OUTCOMES THIS IS
ESPECIALLY PROBLEMATIC AMONG
OUR YOUTH. ACCORDING TO THE
CDC'S NATIONAL YOUTH TOBACCO
SURVEY YOUR 20% OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS REPORTED CURRENT E.
CIGARETTE USE AND ABOUT 40%
REPORTED HEAVY USE OF E.
CIGARETTES THE AVAILABILITY OF
YOUTH APPEALING FLAVORS SUCH AS
GUMMY BEARS AND COTTON CANDY H.
ALONG WITH HEAVY MARKETING HAS
IN LARGE PART CONTRIBUTED TO
THIS TREND TOBACCO RETAILERS
ARE MORE PREVALENT IN THE
POOREST AND MOST ETHNICALLY
DENSE NEIGHBORHOODS WHICH
INCLUDES POPULATIONS MOST AT
RISK OF INADEQUATE HEALTH CARE
ACCESS AND COVERAGE. THAT IS
WHY I HAVE INTRODUCED SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY FIVE WHICH
PROPOSES CLOSER TAX PARITY
BETWEEN THE SALE OF VAPE AND
TRADITIONAL TOBACCO PRODUCTS
PROCEEDS OF THE REVENUE
GENERATED GO TOWARDS EXISTING
VOTER APPROVED SOURCES
INCLUDING EARLY CHILDHOOD
SERVICES PUBLIC HEALTH AND
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
AND FUNDING FOR PHYSICIAN
STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS
FOR THOSE WORKING IN OUR MOST
THIS. STUDENT WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY WITNESSES
KATE WILBUR WHO IS A YOUTH
ADVOCATE WITH THE SAN BENITO
YOUTH ASSOCIATION. AND SHANNON
BECAUSE LOVICH PROGRAM MANAGER
FOR EQUALITY CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU- WITH THE SAN BENITO YOUTH
ASSOCIATES- WE HAVE YOUR PERSON
MY GOODNESS MY FIRST IN PERSON
ON THIS WELCOME GO AHEAD PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KATE WILBUR
AND I'M THE CHAIRPERSON FOR THE
SAN BENITO YOUTH ASSOCIATION
FOR THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS MY
GROUP AND I HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO EDUCATE OUR COMMUNITY ON THE
DANGERS OF YOUTH TOBACCO USAGE.
SEEING MY FELLOW STUDENTS
VAPING IN MY HIGH SCHOOL
BATHROOMS AND SEEING EMPTY
JEWEL PODS ON THE STREETS OF MY
COMMUNITY REALLY WOKE ME UP TO
HOW SERIOUS THIS PROBLEM IS BUT
THIS PROBLEM ISN'T JUST IN SAN
BENITO COUNTY IT IS AN EPIDEMIC
THAT IS AFFECTING YOU ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION YOUTH
USERS ARE FAR MORE LIKELY TO
BECOME LIFELONG TOBACCO USERS.
WITH MORE SEVERE ADDICTIONS.
AND BIG TOBACCO IS TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS FACT- VAPING
PRODUCTS THEY ARE TARGETING AND
HOOKING KIDS AT AN EARLIER AGE
WHEN THEY ARE MORE VULNERABLE
AND MORE LIKELY TO BECOME
LIFELONG ATTICS. AND SADLY
THEIR PREDATORY TACTICS HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL VAPING WITH
THEIR FLAVORS AND TARGETED ADS
ARE NOW MORE PREVALENT AMONGST
YOUTH THAN ANY OTHER AGE GROUP.
SADLY THE YOUTH VOTE A VAPING
EPIDEMIC HAS ALSO SKYROCKETED
OMITS THE PANDEMIC HIGHER
LEVELS OF DEPRESSION ANXIETY
AND THE ISOLATION HAVE ALL
CONTRIBUTED TO HIGHER YOUTH
VAPING RATES. PRODUCTS ARE ALSO
MORE ACCESSIBLE THAN EVER WITH
ONLINE RETAILERS AND THAT IS
WHY SB THREE NINETY FIVE IS SO
IMPORTANT. THE ADDED TAX WOULD
HELP DISCOURAGE YOUNGER USERS
AND MICHALEK TRONIC TOBACCO
PRODUCTS LESS AVAILABLE
MEANWHILE THE PROCEEDS WOULD GO
TO ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND
TOBACCO. PREVENTION EDUCATION.
THE STATE MUST TAKE STEPS
IMMEDIATELY. TO PROTECT YOUTH
USERS AND PREVENT THEM FROM
LIFETIMES OF SUFFERING AND
STRUGGLE WITH THE DICTION. IT'S
LEGISLATION LIKE SB THREE
NINETY FIVE THAT COULD HAVE
HELPED MY COUSIN FROM BECOMING
ADDICTED AND GETTING KICKED OUT
OF HIS HIGH SCHOOL. SB THREE
NINETY FIVE SUPPORTS
CALIFORNIAN YOUTH. AND WOULD
HELP PREVENT THEM FROM MAKING
NEGATIVE CHOICES WITH PERMANENT
AFFECTS. I URGE YOU TO JOIN ME
IN THE FIGHT FOR OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE AND THEIR FUTURES WITH
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
AND I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE-
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA ONLINE
MODERATOR IF YOU TO OPEN THEM
OPARA OPEN UP THE LINE. I DON'T
SEE ANYONE- HERE TO PROVIDE A
WITNESS. OKAY I THINK WHEN WE
GO AHEAD AND JUST MOVE TO ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT ON THIS ITEM
SB THREE NINETY FIVE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SELL SUPPORT FOR SB THREE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE FIVE IN Q. MY TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HER NUMBER
KAREN LAYING ON TOP OF THE
SOLANO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT TODAY
THINKING OF. MY TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT BACK IN
DOLLARS NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. I DON'T.
THANK EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BUT THE ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
DENNIS TELL US ABOUT ALL.
MEDICAL INSTITUTIONS. NINE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M TERM
MEMBER STEVEN KRIEGER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRIBUTORS
ASSOCIATION'S BOARD OF SB THREE
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. LINE
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS REFUTED THREE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINETY FIVE
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MARGARET GOULD WITH THE FIRST
FIVE ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
THE FIFTY FIRST BY COUNTY
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. BEFORE WE GO TO
LINE FORTY TWO OTHER REMINDER
IF YOU LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
SB THREE NINETY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THEIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS WILLIE MCKAY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. AND AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE ON
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
THE- VIDEO CONFERENCING CENTER.
NOPE SEEING NINE. IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE LINE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB THREE NINETY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OKAY WHAT'S
THE NUMBER AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU LIKE TO SHOP FOR SB THREE
NINETY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. I DON'T KNOW WHEN SHOWN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S AN
ISSUE WITH THE MAIN A WITNESS
LINE FOR THOSE WHO ARE MAIN
WITNESSES WHO NEED TO TESTIFY
YOU CAN USE THE REGULAR CALLING
NUMBER WHICH IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. AND THAT INFORMATION IS ON
THE BOTTOM OF YOUR TV SCREEN IF
YOU NEED IT AGAIN. ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THOSE IN THE
COMMUNITY. QUINN COMMITTEE.
NAME ANY. SEEING NONE. SENATOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL LANGUAGE
WHICH I DO HAVE ONE CENTER I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE COMMITTED TO
TAKING A MOMENT IN HEALTH TO
ADDRESS REVENUE ALLOCATION
CONCERNS YES THAT'S GOOD THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY- ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU MS HIGHLY
CALDERON JR I NEED A MOTION
AND- A MOTION AND A SECOND. I
HAVE A MOTION BY KIRK SECOND BY
GRAY. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
HEALTH. ON THE BILL BURKE ALL
RIGHT ALL RIGHT WHEN NOT VOTING
GRAY. GREAT I GRAYSON GRAYSON
ONLINE LEVINE LEVINE I MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
WORK BURKE I RIVAS. ZERO ZERO
NO. SIXTY ONE THE BILL HAS
PASSED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH US
OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE
HAVE TWO OTHERS REMAINING
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND PORCHES.
YEAH. I'M SURE I CAN GO BACK
AND GET LOTS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
BACK TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR ADELINES WITH THAILAND
ABSENTEES WHEN I PRAY. I MULLIN
RIVAS.
BOB WITHOUT A WORD- YEAH.
RIGHT.
COOL COOL COOL. YEAH.
YEAH RIGHT. I MEAN- OKAY. YEAH.
YEAH. WOW THE. FIRE. OPERATORS
HERE YEAH. FILE ITEM ONE SB
THREE OH THREE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON I
APOLOGIZE WE WERE STILL IN
FLOOR SESSION. ALL THIS JUMP
RIGHT IN JUST JUMP ON. THANK
YOU THERE YOU GO DO YOU WISH
FOR ME TO SHORT AND SWEET. VERY
VERY SHORT SWEET- IN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE BUTTE FIRE
BURNED DOWN THE HOME OF A
COUPLE IN MY DISTRICT. THEY
BEGIN THE REBUILDING PROCESS
FOLLOWING THE FIRE IN THEIR
FIRST ESTIMATED COMPLETION WAS
NOVEMBER OF NINETEEN. WHICH IS
FURTHER JUST AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY JUST IN TIME FOR THEM
UTILIZED THE BASE VALUE
TRANSFER. IN SHORT. WE ARE
EXTENDING FROM FIVE YEARS TO
SEVEN YEARS THE ABILITY TO
TRANSFER THE BASE VALUE FOR
THOSE THAT ARE REBUILDING- OR
PURCHASING PROPERTIES AND THE
COUNTY WHERE THE PROPERTY WAS
DAMAGED IT'S A VERY SIMPLE BILL
BUT I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU SENATOR I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S ONE PRIMARY WITNESS WE
SHOULDN'T TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
WITH THE MODERATOR PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH OTHER CALAVERAS
COUNTY ASSESSOR. HI LESLIE
DAVIS IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE IF YOU ROLE
WILL BE GLAD TO OPEN UP YOUR
LINE FOR YOU. THANK YOU. THE
SENSOR ARE YOU THERE. YES I AM
YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
LESLIE DAVIS CALAVERAS COUNTY
ASSESSOR I'M SPEAKING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THREE OH
THREE I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
APOLOGIST FOR AUTHORIZED
AUTHORING THE BILL AND IT
KNOWLEDGE THE HARD WORK AND HIS
STAFF INCLUDING MEGAN DECISION
DATED JORGENSEN. SENATE BILL
THREE OH THREE RECOGNIZES THE
STATE WIDE IMPACT OF THE CODE
OF THE PANDEMIC ON OWNERS WHO
ARE STRUGGLING TO OVERCOME THE
IMPACT OF A LARGE SCALE
DISASTER AND WHO THEN RAN INTO
ROADBLOCKS THAT DELAYED THEIR
ABILITY TO REBUILD SB THREE OH
THREE WILL EXTEND A HELPING
HAND TO SURVIVORS. OF THOSE
NATURAL DISASTERS ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE BEEN HIT BY A DOUBLE
WHAMMY FIRST A FIRE OR FLOOD
AND THEN A PANDEMIC THE
CALIFORNIA ASSESSORS
ASSOCIATION HAS TAKEN A SUPPORT
POSITION ON SB THREE OH THREE.
TOGETHER WITH MY COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEAK THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU THE MODERN
NOW OPEN THE MAINLINE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF SUPPORT OF SB
THREE OH THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD JUST BECAUSE
SUPPORT OF SB THREE OH THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I
SHOW NO ONE SHOWING SUPPORT
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE REMOTE REMOTE VIEWING ROOM.
SEEING NINE IS THERE A-
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE MAIN LINE WITH OPPOSITION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE TO
ZERO FOR SB THREE OH THREE.
WHAT THE INITIAL OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE OH THREE MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
OPPOSING THE BILL I THINK YOU
ANYONE INTERVIEW IN THE VIDEO
REMOTE ROOM SEEING NONE. ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE OF STARK
BURKE. SO FOR PERSONAL WHICH
WITH YOUR PROJECT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOCTOR CLARK YOU TURN
YOUR MIKE I THINK A GOOD IDEA.
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO IS HAVE
BEEN EVER MUCH. ALL I AM CAN IS
A KNOW THE- IMAGE IS. THAT
THERE IS TO DO. OF P. TO SIGN
UP FOR THIS BECAUSE THE FIRST
FEW PEOPLE WHO SIGN UP MAY END
UP. PAYING ALL THE SET UP FEES.
I KNOW YOU SAID THAT THE MONEY%
SHOULD COME FROM THE GENERAL
FUND BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S TOO
LATE TO ASK FOR IT IF IT'S- NO
THAT'S NOT IT THAT'S ON A NOT
FIVE FIVE FIVE. NINE FIVE FIVE
FIVE I'M SORRY. WRONG ONE I
DON'T HAVE A COMMENT OKAY I'M
THINKING AND WIRES YES YEAH
HE'S ON TO MY NEXT BILL ARE
EVEN MORE BUT- I THINK ASSEMBLY
QUIRK IS ACTUALLY. RIGHT- I'D
LOVE TO GET MONEY FOR. NUMBER
MANY FEELS. I'M WITH THAT
SENATOR SORRY BY THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COOK ALL EXCEPT- THE
COMMITTEE OF AMENDMENTS AND-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION RESPECT WESTERN
AYE BUT I BELIEVE WE HAD A
MOTION AND A SECOND SOME IS
HIGHLY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL
THE ROSS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS ON
THE BILL BURKE. HI BURKE ALL
RIGHT WHEN I GRAY GRAYSON-
GRAYSON I LEVINE LEVINE I MAYES
MAYES AYE MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS ARTWORK HI
CORRECT I RIVAS HEY ARNOLD HI
ZERO I. BILL PASSES EIGHT ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT OF THANK YOU
SENATOR HERE FOR THOSE WHO ARE
LISTENING CURRENT COMMITTEE WE
ON OUR LAST AUTHOR SO IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME DOWN WE WOULD
APPRECIATE IT SENATOR MCGUIRE
IF YOU LIKE TO OPEN. AND WE'RE
STARTING WITH FILE ITEM FIVE SB.
FIVE FIVE FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE ITEMS IN THE GAME OF
THAT A VICE CHAIR UP FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO ALWAYS THINK
THIS YEAR WE'VE HAD THE ABILITY
TO SPEAK ABOUT THIS BILL- LATE
LAST WEEK OVER THE WEEKEND AND
I'M SURE I JUST WANNA SAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- DO DILIGENCE IS
ALWAYS AN HONOR TO BE TO WORK
WITH YOU. I EACH AND EVERY YEAR
I'M ALSO GRATEFUL THAT A PRISON
SB FIVE FIVE FIVE WHICH WOULD
CREATE A NEW THE INNOVATIVE
SYSTEM FOR COLLECTING
DISPENSING REVENUE FROM BED
TAXES ALSO KNOWN AS T. O. T.
FOR SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS. NOW IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW- NEARLY EVERY CITY
AND COUNTY LEVEL OF THAT TAX IN
THAT REVENUE COLLECTED AS YOU
ALL KNOW IS TYPICALLY USED FOR
GENERAL FUND PURPOSES THAT-
SUPPORT ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT
SERVICE YOU KNOW UNLIKE HOTELS
AND MOTELS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AWFUL- QUITE OFTEN HAVE A
DIFFICULT TIME COLLECTING THESE
PAY TAXES FOR SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS. BECAUSE HOSTS
ARE NOT ALWAYS AWARE OF THE
REQUIREMENT TO BE ABLE TO
COLLECT AND REMIT THESE TAXES
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DO NOT
ALWAYS KNOW WHAT PROPERTIES ARE
BEING USED FOR THE SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS THIS IS BEEN
AN ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO TACKLE CANDIDLY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN MY FIRST YEAR
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THEREFORE WHAT WE KNOW IS
LIKELY TENS OF MILLIONS MOST
LIKELY HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS IN
BED TAX REVENUE GOES
UNCOLLECTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
EVERY YEAR SO WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO IT WOULD HELP CITIES
AND COUNTIES COLLECT THIS
UNTAPPED REVENUE BY CREATING A
STATEWIDE BED TAX COLLECTION
PROGRAM. ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION- FOR
LOCAL G. JURISDICTIONS WHO
CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE THIS IS
1100% VOLUNTARY- IT'S MODELED
AFTER THE HARD WORK THAT YOU'RE
A WOMAN BURKE DID WITH THE
MARKET PLACE FACILITATOR ACT.
THIS PROGRAM AT FOR ONLINE
VACATION RULES REQUIRE SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTAL
FACILITATORS SUCH AS AIRBNB OR
VR BO THE COLLECTED AT THE
APPROPRIATE DATE TAX FROM
CUSTOMERS WHEN A SHORT TERM
RENTAL IS BOOKED THROUGH THE
PLATFORM. THAT PLATFORM WITHIN
REMIT THE FUNDS TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION WHO THEN
DISTRIBUTE. THE REVENUE ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS TO THE C. AND-
AGAIN THIS PROGRAM IS 1% AND
LOCAL AGENCIES WOULD NEED TO BE
ABLE TO- ENACT AN ORDINANCE TO
PARTICIPATE THIS BILL DOES NOT
TOUCH VOLUNTARY COLLECTION
AGREEMENTS WITH PLATFORMS THOSE
VOLUNTARY COLLECTION AGREEMENTS
THAT A FEW DOZEN CITIES ALREADY
HAVE- WOULD BE GRANDFATHERED
IN. SB FIVE FIVE FIVE SIMPLY
GIVES JURISDICTIONS WHO HAVE
NOT FOUND SUCCESS IN ENTERING
INTO THESE VCA IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
COLLECT THE TAXES IT THERE DO
WE ANTICIPATE THERE ARE FEW
HUNDRED CITIES IN THE STATE
THEY DON'T HAVE A VOLUNTARY
COLLECTION AGREEMENT AND IT
ALSO ENSURES THAT ALL HOSTING
PLATFORMS- ARE ON A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD TO BE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT TODAY VENTURE WE
PRESIDENT CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
SPENDING CHAMBERS- AND- WE ALSO
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE. FROM THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
ON THE LINE AND IT SURE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
DON'T AT THE MOST APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE CONNECT US
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HISPANIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE FIRST
PLEASE. YES MA'AM KEVIN JULIAN.
HI GO AHEAD. THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DOING
COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA ISPANIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE
CALIFORNIA BACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND IT'S OVER ONE
HUNDRED FIVE CHAMBERS AND
AFFILIATES REPRESENT THE
INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY IT IS FALL
BUSINESSES AND HISPANIC
COMMUNITY WHO ARE PROACTIVE
EDUCATION ADVOCACY EFFORTS ON
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES THAT
ANSWER AND MEET. THE NEEDS OF
THE TWO COMMUNITIES WE WRITE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF CHAMBER
CHOIRS SB FIVE FIVE FIVE. SB
FIVE FIVE FIVE OFFERS OUR STATE
AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES A QUICK
AND EFFECTIVE SOLUTION TO
COLLECTING A DISPENSING
CHAMPION OCCUPANCY TAXES ARE
TAX REVENUE FROM SHORT TERM
RENTALS AND HOUSING. AS A
RESULT OF COVERT NINETEEN
CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
PROJECTED- TO FACE SEVERE
BUDGET SHORTFALLS ASTERISM
RETURNS THE CALIFORNIA- TLT
WILL SERVE AS AN IMPORTANT AND
NOBLE TOOL THAT WILL ALLOW
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TIMIDLY TAP
INTO DIGITAL DOLLARS AND WE
INVEST THESE TAX REVENUES BACK
INTO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES. T.
O. P. H. YOU KNOW PLAYS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO BE INVESTED IN
FIRE POLICE SERVICES LOCAL
SCHOOLS LIBRARIES AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS THAT WILL
PROCOPIO COMEDIES AND SAFE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND WHAT IS GOOD
FOR COMMUNITIES IS GOOD FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES WE URGE SWIFT
PASSAGE OF SB FIVE FIVE FIVE TO
EIGHT CALIFORNIA'S POST
PANDEMIC ECONOMIC. RECOVERY
AFTER SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SMALL BUSINESSES AND VITAL
PUBLIC SERVICES THAT RELY ON
THE T. O. P. RABBANI I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. OF
OUR COMMON THIS AFTERNOON. THE
YOU ALL OF THEM NOW CONNECT US
WITH THE SILICON LEADERS GROUP.
GOOD AFTERNOON NAME IS I
REMEMBER BY PRESIDENT REALLY
FOR THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERS
GROUP A COOKING WRAP. THE THREE
AND TO GIVE CONVALLIS MORE
RESPECT DEBT EMPLOYERS ON
ISSUES AFFECT THE INNOVATION
ECONOMY I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK
ON THIS BILL WHICH ESTABLISHES
A NEW INNOVATIVE AND
STREAMLINED STATEWIDE SYSTEM
FOR COLLECTING AND DISPENSING
POT REVENUE FOR SHORT TERM
RENTAL HOUSING PLATFORMS. SB
FIVE BY FIVE OFFERED A CLEAR
TRANSPARENT PATH FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES WITHOUT AN EXISTING
TAX COLLECTION AGREEMENT WITH
HOSTING PLATFORMS TO ENSURE
THEY RECEIVE THE TOT REVENUES
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO IT AND
OFTEN BILL SHOULD HAVE CITY OR
COUNTY DECIDE. NOT TO OPT INTO
THE PROGRAM THEY'RE CLICKING
TACTIC REMAINS ARE PROTECTED
AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WITHOUT
AN EXISTING TAX AGREEMENT ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE. I
THINK EVEN COUNTY THE MERGE
FROM THE PANDEMIC AND BEGIN TO
WELCOME TRAVELERS AND TOURISM
BACK INTO THEIR COMMUNITIES SB
FIVE BY FIVE INSURERS THERE'S A
PATHWAY TO COLLECT MUCH NEEDED
TOT REVENUES TO SUPPORT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL WOULD ENSURE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD BY REQUIRING ALL
LOSING PLATFORMS TO SUPPORT TAX
COLLECTOR AND SHOULD A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS OFTEN
FURTHERMORE- SB FIVE FIVE FIVE
SUPPORT CONSUMER TRANSPARENCY
BY ENSURING GAP HAVE.
VISIBILITY OF LOCAL HOTEL TAXES
THAT ARE DUE DURING THE BOOKING
PROCESS AND WE LOOK TO RECOVER
FROM THE PANDEMIC TOURISM IS A
KEY PART OF THAT EQUATION AND
THAT'S THE L. G. URGES THE
REVENUE AND TAX COMMITTEE.
PASSED SB. FIVE FIVE FIVE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
ARE. CAN WE HAVE THE WITNESS
AND SOME TEST NOW. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE FIVE FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE
DIFFERENTLY WITH OPERATORS
THANK YOU MY PLEASURE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE ONE FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ADAM THOMAS
WHAT WHAT AIRBNB IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THE
MOTHER WAITING FOR EVERYONE TO
QUEUE UP LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AS A REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO NINE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR BURKE
AFTER A MOTHER FOR ON BEHALF OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH SHORT TERM
RENTAL ALLIANCE CALLING TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE FIVE
FIVE THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN
HURTS CALLING IN TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. ONE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HEATHER
CARSON CO FOUNDER OF THE HOME
SURE ALLIANCE LOS ANGELES ALL
ADVOCATES FOR FAIR REGULATIONS
FOR THE WORKING CLASS MOM AND
POP SHORT TERM RENTAL APPROACH
THAT HOME SHARED LOS ANGELES.
WE ARE VOLUNTEER BASED
GRASSROOTS NOT AFFILIATED OR
FUNDED BY ANY SHORT TERM RENTAL
BOOKING PLATFORMS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FIVE FIVE FIVE THANK
YOU. NINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LINDA LIGHTHIZER WITH THE STAMP
AND FISCAL HOME SHARES
DEMOCRATIC CLUB CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE FIVE
THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS PETER COHEN- I'M A
BOARD MEMBER AND SOLUBLE WE
SHARED TO MCCARTY CLUB
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR HUNDRED.
CHILDREN WHICH WILL HOST IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND WILL CERTAINLY IN
FAVOR OF SB FIVE BY FIVE THANK
YOU. ANDAT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE ON SUPPORT. I THINK
YOU DO HAVE ANY SUPPORT IN THE
VIDEO STATION AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM SEEING NONE I WENT
TO- MODERATE IF YOU COULD OPEN
THE LINE FOR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB FIVE FIVE
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WHAT THE INITIAL
OPPOSITION DEMOCRATS WANTED.
ZERO OUR MOTION MANSIONS NIKOLA
KALINIC OPERATIONS. THANK YOU.
I'M SORRY GO AHEAD THE WHAT MAY
NOT BE SUFFICIENT GO OUT YES
I'M SORRY. MISTER BROWN OKAY NO
COMMENTS THANK YOU. NUMBER
SEVEN ON THE GROUND ON BEHALF
OF THE BIG COMPANIES THEY ARE
BUT I WANT TO THANK US SENATE
MCGUIRE IT BEING SUCH A GREAT
CHAMPION FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
TIED UP AND THEN INCLUDED A
CANCER- POST. HI AT THE TOP
FIVE- TO BE FIT THIS AGREE WITH
THE APPROACH ME AND- MORE CITY
AND HOW THE BEST ADDRESS. A
REAL- GROWING ISSUE OF
COLLECTING OCAL TAXES AND
CHARGES I FOUND THE FROM THE
BOOMING SHORT TERM RENTAL
INDUSTRY OUT TRYING TO FIND AN
AWESOME PROGRAM WE DO BILLION
ACCIDENTAL AND DISRUPT NINE
FIFTEEN FIVE CONTRACTS- THAT
ACTIVISION ALSO I'M TO A KEY
REVENUE SOURCE THAT HAS DULY
NOTED BY CITIES I HAVE-
SICKENING DROPS IN THROUGHOUT
THE LAST YEAR. AND MOVING INTO
THE NEXT YEAR WE ARE CONCERNED
ON. THE BASEMENT CONSTANT
DESTRUCTION. HOW WE TALKING
WITHIN ACROSS STATE THANK
GENERAL WOULD LEAD SB FIVE
FIVE. DOES NOT SAW. THE PROBLEM
OF SO A MENTAL. CONTACT FOR
THERE HOW A ANTI PROPERTY
OWNERS NOT. PROVIDING
TRANSPARENT THE KEY INFORMATION.
FOR A POP COLLECTION OF LUCK
TAXES. AND CHARGES INCLUDING
THE HOTEL ATTACK. I ALSO HEAR-
THE WHOLE INDUSTRY WHILE THE-
THANK YOU HOW COME. IN A TAXES
TO. THAT WE NEED HAVE. A FROM
FROM EACH DAY. MEETING A LOCAL
OF THE RENTAL. RATE DASH CHARGE-
ON THE SHORT TERM. AND DURATION
STAY IS A IN THE- AND I- AND
THE PASTOR. NOT NOT BEEN THE
BEST PART EVEN IF YOU'RE- I
THINK ABOUT THE WEATHER A HARD.
TO GET THE INFORMATION HE'S NOT
GOING ON ON THE SIDE AND THIS
ISSUE CITY. ACROSS THE STATE OF
COURT STAFF. WE'VE BEEN HERE
THE CONTACT WITH COMPLIANCE
MANY THAT MARKETS SHORT TERM
O'CLOCK ONE TWENTY FOURTH THAT.
THREE SIXTY FIVE SUCH A WHERE
THAT OKAY OF ALL SHORT TERM ARE.
ON THE DURATION STANDING RIGHT
BEEN STATE TO. COLLECT OF THE
HOTEL TAX. SO I THOUGHT I THEN
PUT TODAY WE BELIEVE. THAT
SHOULD BE AMENDED. TO WITHOUT
AND THIS INFORMATION TELL TO DO
NAY AND CONTRACTING. CAN THE
COP. AND I KNEW SYSTEM. I
WANTED OUT IN THE COMING OUT
THE WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CAR AND THEN WE- IN. ARE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE A LAPTOP
CARRY OUT THIS PROGRAM. WE NOW
FOR MARKETING A CITY THAT IS
THE TOP PERCENT THREE SIXTY
FIVE MILES OUT. THE PLATFORM
LET'S THE NEEDED. BOB THIS IS A
THING IN TO GET WILL BE TECH ON
FILE WITH A VERY LOW BENEFITS
THE STATE I TOLD WE ARE
CONCERNED. ABOUT THE LOOK OF
THE- BUT WE DO. HAVE A LIST FOR
OUR NINETY CAMPAIGN PARTNERS.
SO THAT THEY CAN THE SENATE-
HAVING SOME ADVOCATE. THANK
COMMITTEE HOPING TO WORK WITH
THE FACT AND- WE TO THE LEFT.
ELECTRIFY TO PROVIDE A PATH TO
ON THIS BILL. AND I THINK YOU
HAVE. THAT. CORRECT TRANSACTION
SEE TAXES ARE COLLECTED FROM
HOTELS AND PNB'S TODAY. EACH
HOTEL OR B. AND B. MUST FILE
QUARTERLY HOTEL ROOM TAX
RETURNS UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY. AND EACH CITY CANNOT
AT ANY HOTEL ANYTIME GOING BACK
UP TO THREE YEARS. UNDER THIS
BILL SHORT TERM RENTALS OWNERS
IN THE CITY WOULD NOT HAVE TO
SUBMIT ANYTHING TO THE CITY.
NOTHING UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY. NO AUDITING BY THE
CITY. INSTEAD IT A STATE TAX
AGENCY WILL TALLY UP THE BILL
BASED ON THE TAX RETURNS ON THE
PLATFORMS LIKE AIRBNB. ANY
PROPERTY NOT ON THE PLATFORM
WHICH DOES GET THE TAXES AND
IT'S COMMON KNOWLEDGE THAT
REGULAR CUSTOMERS A SHORT TERM
RENTALS GENERALLY DEAL DIRECTLY
WITH THE RENTAL OWNERS TO AVOID
THE SERVICE FEE LEVIED BY THE
PLATFORMS. AGAIN THOSE
TRANSACTIONS WITH ESCAPE THE
DOT. THE RESULT THAT THAT IF
THE RESULT IS THAT MANY SHORT
TERM RENTALS STAYS WILL NOT PAY
THE T. O. T. GIVEN THAT MOST
YOUR TEARS ARE IN EXCESS OF 10%
THAT'S A HUGE COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE TO HOTELS. AND B.
AND B. IS THAT PLAY BY THE
RULES. WE AGREE WITH THE LEAGUE
THAT THE ONLY WAY TO MAKE THIS
THING WORK IS TO GIVE THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES ACCESS TO
THE INFORMATION NEEDED TO
INSURE PROPER COLLECTION AND
AUDITING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE CAN OPEN THE LINE TO ANY
OTHER ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
PLEASE TESTIMONY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN DO SO OPPOSITION FOR
SB FIVE FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY
TWENTY FIVE IN TAKING YOURSELF
OUT OF Q. PRESS ONE AND THEY'RE
ALL OPEN UP YOUR LINE. YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I DON'T OPEN
MY LOWER BACK OKAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE OUR PERSPECTIVE WITH YOU
TODAY MY NAME IS AMIT O'KEEFE
WITH BOOKING DOT COM BOOKING IS
AN ONLINE ACCOMMODATION
PLATFORMS BASED IN AND WITH
THIS IS WE'VE HAD THE TWO
PRIMARY PURPOSES WE HAD THE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME ITS NAME. AND
POSITION. NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION PLEASE. AND IT'LL KEEP
WITH BOOKING DOT COM ARE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION- WE LIKE
YOU CAN AMENDMENT TO THE BILL.
IT HAD A CLARIFIED REGARDING
PAYMENTS OKAY- AND- RIGHT NOW
WE'RE ONLY TAKING PRIMARY WHICH
WE TOOK THE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SOON
OUR AIM AT THE REGION IN
OPPOSITION HOWEVER I AM I
BELIEVE YOU'RE A MOMENT HAS
BEEN COMMUNICATED TO THE AUTHOR
AT THIS TIME. NEXT BIGGER IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE MODERATOR.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SPEAK UP IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE IF YOU'RE A LACK OF
TIME. AND I DON'T KNOW WHEN
I'LL SHOWING OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
VIDEO REMOTE VIDEO ROOM NO. I
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE OKAY MR MAYS.
WITH THE MESSAGE CARE ACT JUST
AS A POINT OF CLARIFICATION-
ACTUALLY HAVE IN MY IN MY
DISTRICT- I'VE GOT CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE ALL OVER THE PLACE
I'VE GOT A COUNTY THAT'S VERY
SUPPORT OF CITY THAT'S VERY
SUPPORTIVE AND WE GOT- SOME
CITIES THAT ARE NEUTRAL AND A
COUPLE CITIES WHO WHO ARE
OPPOSED- SO JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT FOR CLARIFICATION
SAKE. BECAUSE YOU'D SAID THAT
YOU CAN IN THE CD CTF IS GOING
TO MANAGE THIS AND THERE ARE
THOSE CITIES COUNTIES THAT
ALREADY HAVE AGREEMENTS WITH-
THOSE WHO ARE PROVIDING THE
SERVICE BUT FOR EVERYBODY ELSE
THAT THAT YOU KNOW THAT THAT
DON'T HAVE A CONTRACT ARE THEY
REQUIRED TO SIGN UP TO THIS OR
DEBATE THE CITIES WOULD HAVE TO
OPT IN. REALLY GOOD QUESTIONS
IN NUMBER THANK YOU SO MUCH
SOONER REYES YOU'RE ACTUALLY
CRACKED 1100% OFTEN AND IN FACT
THAT JUST BEING HONEST ABOUT
THIS WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET
AT THIS BILL- IN THIS ISSUE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. AND
IN FACT IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
WE HAD A BILL THAT WOULD
RELEASE THE INDIVIDUALIZED
ADDRESSES FOR HOSTS FOR ALL
ONLINE ALL ONLINE EDUCATIONAL
PLATFORMS IN IT DIED A PAINFUL
DEATH JUST BEING CANDID
COULDN'T GET THE VOTES FOR WE
TRY TO GET IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND IT DIED AGAIN. SO%
NOW WE'RE BACK WITH A STOP GAP
MEASURE THAT IS OPTIONAL I COME
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT FOR THE
CITY COUNCIL BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS- AND ADD. WHAT
WOULD HAVE TO HAPPEN IS IF YOU
LIVE IN THE CITY OF SAN RAFAEL
FOR EXAMPLE THE CITY CENTER
FELT THEY DIDN'T HAVE A
VOLUNTARY COLLECTION AGREEMENT
THEY WOULD HAVE TO PASS AN
ORDINANCE TO BE ABLE TO OBTAIN
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS- THEY WOULD
NEED TO STRIKE THAT AGREEMENT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION. BUT
IF. YOU DO NOT OFTEN YOU DON'T
COLLECT. SO I. STEP QUO IF YOU
DO NOT ON. IT'S HUNDRED PER
BALLING. ON THE CITY OR
COUNTY'S. THANK YOU- JUST SAY
THAT I'M TRYING TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY I THINK IT'S THE- OF
THE LORD'S WORK THAT YOU'RE-
THAT YOU'RE DOING HERE I KNOW
THAT THE- THE ISSUES THAT THAT
COME WITH THIS. MY GUESS IS FOR
SOME OF THE COMMUNITIES THERE
OPPOSED TO BECAUSE- THEY LIKE
TO COLLECT OTHER PENALTIES-
THAT COME FROM- FROM NOT NOT
PROPERLY PAYING I KNOW IF YOU
COMMUNITIES THAT DO THAT THAT
ACTUALLY RECEIVE A- SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF. REVENUE BECAUSE OF
THE PENALTIES IN THIS WOULD
STREAMLINE THE WHOLE PROCESS
AND SO ON THANK YOU FOR THIS
WORK ON THE SUPPORTING IT
TODAY. THANK YOU SOMEONE. THANK
YOU DR CURRICULA QUESTION. NO
I'M JUST CONCERNED ABOUT- SOME
PRACTICAL ASPECTS AGAIN I'M FOR
I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR THE BILL
OF AFFORD ON THE FLOOR BUT I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH OF THIS IS
REALLY PRACTICAL FOR EXAMPLE
SOME CITIES ACCORDING TO THE
ANALYSIS. TAX BASED ON THE LIST
PRICE NOW. WHAT I WOULD
ENVISIONED- THE TAX AUTHORITY
DOING HERE IS PEOPLE SEND IN
THEIR TAX BILL IN APRIL. YOU
CAN SEE WHAT THE GROCERY SEATS
WHERE WHAT THEIR TAXABLE
RECEIPTS WERE- HOPEFULLY
EVERYTHING CAN BE TIED IN WITH
COMPUTERS. BUT WHEN YOU SAY CAN
BE DONE WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
REALLY DONE- LET'S ASK EIGHTY
D. ABOUT THEIR COMPUTER SYSTEM
SO I HAVE SOME SKEPTICISM- BUT
THE TOUGHER PART IS IF IT IS
BASED UPON THE LIST PRICE. WHO
HAS THAT INFORMATION. THE LIST
PRICE AT THE TIME OF THE RENTAL
COULD BE QUITE DIFFERENT THAN
THE LIST PRICE THAT'S AVAILABLE.
MORE THAN A YEAR AFTER THE
ACTUAL WORK AND YOU CAN SAY ALL
RIGHT THAT'LL BE SENT IN BY THE
CITY THAT SEEMS LIKE THE BEST
WAY TO DO IT. I'M JUST NOT SURE
YOU CAN GET ALL THAT TOGETHER
AND DO IT RIGHT BYE. BYE LESS
THAN IT WELL ABOUT A YEAR FROM
NOW. SOON THE BILL PASSES- I
JUST. I'VE BEEN INVOLVED ENOUGH
A LOT OF COMPUTER SYSTEMS AND
THEY DON'T ALWAYS WORK. THE
SECOND THING I'M WORRIED ABOUT
AND- WHEN THEN PERHAPS YOU
COULD ANSWER THAT AND ALSO WHAT
DISCUSSIONS HAVE YOU HAD WITH-
THE TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THIS WORK
THE REASON WHY WE MODELED- THIS
BILL OFF OF THE CHAIRWOMAN'S
ONLINE FACILITATOR ACT.
LEGISLATION IS BECAUSE THE
SYSTEM IS ALREADY BEEN
CORRECTED I HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CREATED SO VERY SIMILAR- THE
ONLINE PLATFORM ON A QUARTERLY
BASIS WOULD TURN IN UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY. THOSE TAX
OBLIGATIONS THOSE BED TAX
OBLIGATIONS FOR THE SPECIFIC
COMMUTING WHICH THEY'RE DOING
BUSINESS IN. CD TFA WOULD THEN
REMIT THOSE- PAYMENTS TO THE
CITY OR COUNTY OF ORIGIN- AND
SO THE SYSTEM IS ALREADY
CREATED WHICH IS GREAT IN
ADDITION CD TFA ALSO COLLECTS-
A UTILITY USERS TAX FOR ALL OF
MUNICIPALITIES AND THEY'RE ALSO
RESPONSE FOR SALES TAX SO. I
HEAR YOU AND WE ALL- HAVE
INCREDIBLE CHALLENGES WITH EDT
BUT THE AGENCY IS INCREDIBLY
BUTTONED UP AND THANK AND I'M
NOT TRYING TO JUST BLOW SMOKE
BECAUSE THAT YOUR WOMAN THIS
YEAR- BUT- THEY- THEY THEY
REALLY HAVE- THE- THEY'VE GONE
THROUGH THE BIG KAHUNA IF YOU
WILL WITH THIS ONLINE
FACILITATOR ACT- IN DEVELOPING
THE SYSTEM. OKAY SO YOU'RE
SAYING THE- CITY AFFECT THE
RENTERS WOULD HAVE TO DO AND
QUARTERLY REPORTS AS TO THEIR
GROSS INCOME ANY NET INCOME IT
WOULD ACTUALLY BE UP TO THE
PLATFORM TO THE PLATFORMS SO
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE AIRBNB OR
EXPEDIA WOULD HAVE TO RENEW IT.
IF THERE IS S. AS IN THE
REMAINS HAD SAID. IF THE CITY
OPSIN. THE PLOT WITH THE REMIT
TO THE CAL APARTMENT T. AND IF.
ON A QUARTERLY BASIS. BASED OFF
OF THOSE RECEIPTS IN THAT
INDIVIDUAL CITY OR COUNTY'S BED
TAX RATE. THAT WILL THOSE
DOLLARS WOULD THEN BE REMITTED
BACK TO THE CITY NOW CD TFA.
FULL TRANSPARENCY AS THEY DO
WITH ONLINE FACILITATOR ACT
DOES TAKE A VERY SMALL MINISTER
TO SEE OFF THE TOP- BUT THAT'S
HOW IT WOULD WORK IT WOULD BE
BASED OFF OF THE ACTUAL
PLATFORM AND NOT THE INDIVIDUAL
HOME USER WHICH IS WHY IT'S SO
CRITICAL THAT THE PLATFORM DOES
IT. SO WE'RE NOT BURNING-
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF-
HOMEOWNERS. ARM SO THE PROBLEM
IS IF THEY'RE DOINGIT BASED ON
TAXABLE RECEIPTS THEN YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT IS AND TOLD.
PEOPLE FILE THEIR TAXES SO YOU
MAY HAVE A QUARTERLY REPORT
WHICH YOU'RE NOT GONNA KNOW
WHAT THE TAXES WERE UNTIL. A
YEAR LATER. IT'S BUT IT'S BASED
OFF OF THOSE QUARTERLY THE DID
THE BOOK OF BUSINESSES THEY DO
IN THAT QUARTER IN THE PAST SO
THEY KNOW SO THE- THE ONLINE
PLATFORM KNOWS. HOW MANY ROOM
NIGHTS SO FOR EXAMPLE IF. OKAY
YOUR TURN BACK GROCERY SEATS.
SOME PEOPLE TAX BASED UPON
TAXABLE. RIGHT INCOME YOU DON'T
KNOW THAT UNTIL THE END OF THE
YEAR AND YOU'VE- PUT UP ALL OF
YOUR INCOME AND ALL OF YOUR
DEDUCTIONS. SO FOR A OF HOPE
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS YOU
WANT CD- THE TAX AND- FIFTH
ALREADY DO THIS BECAUSE THEY
PRESUMABLY HAVE THE TAX
INFORMATION BUT THAT TAX
INFORMATION ISN'T AVAILABLE
QUARTERLY IT'S AVAILABLE. AFTER
YOU FINISH THE YEAR AND YOU
SUBTRACT EXPENSES FROM INCOME
WELL CURRENTLYRIGHT NOW WE'RE
JUST MODELING THIS OFF OF AND
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE- NOT NOT
TRYING TO- GO AROUND YOUR
QUESTION THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THIS. SO RIGHT NOW IF FOR
EXAMPLE THE CITY OF HILLS
BURKE. COLLECTS AND THEY
ALLOWED VACATION RENTALS- IN
THE TO VOLUNTARY COLLECTION
AGREEMENT THE CITY HILLS BURKE
WITH AIRBNB WOULD GET A CHECK
EVERY QUARTER BASED OFF OF THE
ACTUAL. DATE BOOK OF BUSINESS I
HEAR YOU IN REGARD TO THE
HOMEOWNER- BUT THAT'S THAT'S
CURRENTLY HOW THIS WOULD BE
STRUCTURED OKAY SO YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
WAY SOME CITIES DO IT. WHERE
IT'S ON TAXABLE INCOME IT WOULD
BE BASED OFF OF THE NUMBER OF
ROOM NIGHTS OKAY SO YOU JUST
SIMPLIFIED IT AND YOU SAID CITY
IF YOU WANT TO DO THIS. YOU
CAN'T DO IT BASED ON TAXABLE
INCOME YOU PROBABLY CAN'T DO IT
BASED ON LIST PRICE YOU HAVE TO
DO IT ON GROSS INCOME AT THE
TIME EXACTLY. THAT THAT ANSWERS
MY QUESTION ONCE YOU'VE GOT
THAT. THEN YES I THINK YOU CAN
DO IT THE SECOND PART OF THIS.
IS IT'S GONNA BE HARD TO SIGN
PEOPLE UP. IF THEY HAVE TO PAY
UP FRONT. FOR BRINGING UP THE
SYSTEM. AND. I WISH YOU HAD
JUST ASK FOR MONEY FROM THE
GENERAL FUND THIS IS A GOOD
YEAR TO GET IT. I DON'T KNOW
BUT I'VE GOTTEN SOME MONEY FROM
THE GENERAL FUND FOR VARIOUS
THINGS THIS YEAR THIS IS HERE
WHEN YOU CRANK UP FOR LOST
TIME. TO JUST FUND THE START UP
ON THIS AND I YOU KNOW I JUST
THINK THINGS WILL GO MUCH
BETTER. IT MIGHT NOT BE TOO
LATE. WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THE BUDGET AGREEMENT IS
GOING TO BE. I JUST WISH YOU
WOULD DO THAT OKAY THEN I THINK
IT WOULD BE MUCH EASIER TO SIGN
PEOPLE UP GOSH ALL RIGHT SO
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING THAT
IT'S JUST GOING TO BE ON
GROCERY SEEDS. THAT WORKS I
LOVE IT. SHOULD BE NO PROBLEM
THANK YOU AND WE ARE LOOKING
AT- START UP COSTS RIGHT NOW ON
A SIMILAR WORK AND I TOOK SOME
NOTES AS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
IN REGARD SEE YOUR REQUEST THAT
WE LOOK FOR START UP- I WANT TO
GO BACK AND TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
FEEDBACK. OKAY THANK YOU.
SACRAMENTO COURSE. OKAY I
APOLOGIZE I AM THE- ONE HOLDING
UP SENATE SESSION AND- AS A
BEEN HOLDING- THE ROLE OPEN.
GUY APOLOGIZE WOULD IT BE
ALRIGHT IF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF COURSE. WORK THAT SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER STEPS IN. I
REALLY. LIKE JACKSONVILLE HIM.
I APOLOGIZE THANK YOU. CORRECT
I APOLOGIZE WE WILL WE WILL BE
VERY GENTLE WITH HIM THANK YOU
CAN ASK. TOUGH QUESTIONS AS YOU
WANT. I'M GONNA MAKE IT UP AS
THEY GO DOOR. LISTEN I DO NOT
KNOW THE WE DIDN'T AND THEN
THANK. DO YOU WANT TO MAKE IT
JUST A CALM. MISTER OKAY
RESIDENTS I MAY HAVE LIED I
THOUGHT WE GOING TO REGION
APPARENTLY NO IT'S OKAY CAN
ANSWER QUESTIONS. REMEMBER
GRAYSON HI IF I CAN'T TAKE IT
TO. FOR ALL THESE YEARS.
SELECCIONA DELIGHTED TO BE ABLE
TO ASK SENATOR HERTZBERG
QUESTION THANK YOU CHAIR MADAM
CHAIR AND- MY COLLEAGUE- FROM
PALM SPRINGS- ALREADY INVOKED-
THE HIGHEST AUTHORITY EMPOWER
MY COLON AT THE LORD'S WORK- SO
NOT SURE IF MY QUESTION REALLY
MATTERS AT THIS POINT- BUT I DO
WANT TO. ASK A QUESTION.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THE BILL IS
LAUDABLE- IN THE EFFORTS OF THE
AUTHOR. NOT ALL ONLINE
OPERATORS OPERATE THE SIX
CORRECT SO YOU HAVE A VERY
PROMINENT OPERATOR. THAT HAS
ONE MODEL BUT THEN THERE ARE
OTHER- ONLINE OPERATORS THAT
OPERATE UNDER A DIFFERENT
MODEL. ONE PROMINENT OPERATOR
TAKES MONEY DIRECTLY FROM THE
PERSON RENTING OR THE SHORT
TERMRENTAL WHEREAS OTHER
ONLINE OPERATORS ARE JUST
FACILITATORS WHERE THEY CONNECT
THE RENTER WITH THE PROPERTY
OWNER THAT'S PROVIDING THE
SPACE. SO IS THIS BILL-
DIFFERENTIATING BETWEEN THE
TWO- SO THAT- THE PERSON THAT
IS TRULY LIABLE FOR PAYING THE
TAX. IS THE ONE ACTUALLY PAYING
THE TAX I BELIEVE IT IS THE
CASE AND I WOULD TELL YOU THAT.
AS WE HAVE OVER THE MANY YEARS
HAVE DEALT WITH THESE ISSUES
WHAT IT WAS INTERNET TAXATION
OR THE LIKE. WILL END AND WE
HAVE DEALT SENATE MCGUIRE
INTRODUCED A BILL LIKE THIS
THAT I DIDN'T PASSED WHEN I WAS
CHAIR OF HIS COMMITTEE- BECAUSE
I DIDN'T THINK IT WAS COOKED-
AND SO IT'S A LOT BETTER NOW.
BUT BUT- LOOKI THINK IT'S
GONNA BE SOME CHALLENGES I
THINK TO SOME CHALLENGES WITH
AGENTS WE SEE WITH GRUBHUB WE
SEE WITH A WHOLE HOST OF OTHER
ISSUES WE FACE THIS. BUT I
THINK THAT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP. WITH RESPECT TO
BASICALLY DEALING WITH THIS
DYNAMIC BETWEEN TRANSPORTATION
ARCHITECTS DOT HOTELS AND HOW
THIS WORKS HOW DO WE SUPPORT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS GET THEM
REVENUES. THERE'S GONNA BE SOME
HICK UPS THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT SO- THE GOOD NEWS IS
TO BE. MORE LEGISLATION NEXT
YEAR WHAT WILL NO DOUBT- HICK
UPS ARE VERY ANNOYING. AND WE
OUR BEST TO TRY TO GET RID OF
THOSE HICCUPS AS QUICK AS
POSSIBLE SO I WOULD JUST SIMPLY
ASK THAT- CENTER STANDING IN
FOR THE AUTHOR THAT YOU AND THE
AUTHOR. AS WELL AS- THOSE
LOOKING AT THE BILL IN THE
FUTURE WOULD BE. VERY COGNISANT
OF THE FACT THAT THERE MIGHT BE
A SITUATION WHERE AN ONLINE
PROVIDER IS. BEING HELD LIABLE
FOR SOMETHING THAT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY NOT LIABLE FOR
ANYTHING THAT WOULD FOLLOW
THANK YOU SIR AND LET ME DO IT
LET ME DO MY BEST TO. HELP IN
THIS SITUATION WE ARE AWARE OF
BOOKING DOT COM'S OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL WE HAVE PROPOSED THE
SENATOR PROPOSED SOME
AMENDMENTS- AS LATE AS TODAY.
THEY DID NOT SATISFY HOWEVER WE
ARE VERY WELL AWARE THAT THEY
HAVE A HYBRID MODEL AND I MADE
I BELIEVE THE CENTER WILL
CONTINUE TO TRY TO WORK TO
FIGURE OUT THE BEST WAY TO NOT
CREATE A LOOPHOLE. FOR THE
OTHERS BUT TO. DEAL WITH THEIR-
EIGHT WITH THEIR INDIVIDUAL
SORT OF SITUATION THAT THEY
FIND THEMSELVES AND I WILL
ENCOURAGE HIM TO DO SO CONTINUE
TO DO SO AS WE HAVE OVER THE
WEEKEND THANK THAT WAS JOIN
WITH YOU MAN AND- YOUR- KNOW.
I'M HERE. I SAW HER IT'S GREAT
THAT YOU'RE HERE- IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AFTER HAVING CONCERNS
WITH THE EARLIER VERSION- IT'S
REALLY FANTASTICAL TO WORK ON
ISSUES LIKE THIS AND FIND THAT
GROUND AND WE'RE CERTAIN
CERTAINLY SOLVING A REAL ISSUE
IN A REAL PROBLEM ONE OF THE
THINGS I THINK THE SENATOR THE
AUTHOR HAD MENTIONED EARLIER
WAS BEING MORE SPECIFIC ABOUT
WHERE THE RENTALS WERE LOCATED
I THINK THAT WAS LIKE ADDRESS
SPECIFICITY- THAT MAYBE YOU HAD
CONCERNS WITH IN. PRIOR
VERSIONS IS THAT RIGHT HE
TOUCHED ME A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE APPREHENSION IN THE IN THE
PRIOR VERSIONS YOU KNOW THOSE
ISSUES THAT'S ALL RIGHT THAT
YOU'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT IT
DIRECTLY RATHER THAN. THAN THE
AUTHORS SO THANK YOU. IT WAS
LIKE FIVE YEARS AGO I THINK.
FEDERAL MEMBER ALL THE DETAILS
BUT MY RECOLLECTION IS HAD TO
DO WITH KIND OF. THE LAND USE
ISSUES AND NEIGHBORS VERSES AND
BEING ANONYMOUS AND WITH THE
CITY COULD STILL GET THE
REVENUE ON THE ONE HAND BUT YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE. THE KINDS OF
OTHER CHALLENGES THAT AFFAIR
OFTEN THE CURRENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SO- THAT WAS A THAT
WAS A BIG ISSUE. YEAH I THINK
WE YOU KNOW. SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE ALL AWARE OF- FROM OUR
COMMUNITIES IS CITIES TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE. THAT'S RIGHT
THESE RENTALS ARE THAT'S RIGHT-
USUALLY BECAUSE THERE'S
SOMETHING PROBLEMATIC ABOUT
THEM MAYBE ALSO WANTED THE T.
O. T. AS WELL- AND THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO. JUST GET A HANDLE ON
IT AS IT'S YOU KNOW.
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE WHICH HAS
A LOT OF TOURISM AND PEOPLE
WANT TO COME FOR A WEEKEND OR
FOR A SHORT STAY- YES SO. DOES
THIS BILL PROVIDE ANY TYPE OF
SPECIFICITY AS TO LIKE WHICH-
PROPERTIES ARE PRODUCING WHAT.
WHAT TAX. I YOU KNOW JOHN
ALLEN'S. I DON'T RECALL TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU YEAH I DON'T
THINK. I DO KNOW THAT I'M SURE
YEAH IT'S SO CD TFA OBVIOUSLY
WILL COLLECT A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF INFORMATION NOW THAT
INFORMATION I BELIEVE AND I'M
WAITING FOR I'LL GET AHEAD NOT
OVER HERE BUT MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT. INFORMATION WILL STAY
IN THE POSSESSION OF CD TFA I'M
GONNA DIS AGGREGATED AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION WILL BE PASSED ON
TO THE LOCALS. IN TIME AND IN
YEAH- AND IT IS IT WAS CREATED
THAT WAY BY DESIGN. OF THE
ISSUES IN THE PAST VERSIONS YET
AT THIS BILL MAYBE WOULDN'T BE
THIS FAR IF IT HAD MORE
SPECIFICITY WHAT ONE THING
THAT'S INTERESTING TO ME IS
UNDERSTANDING. THE TAXABLE
INCOME OR THE REVENUE WILL. BUY
A PROPERTY OR TYPE OF PROPERTY
I MEAN THAT'S NOT. NECESSARILY
LOCATION SPECIFIC BUT WE HAVE
THE TAP THIS TYPE OF
GRANULARITY TO UNDERSTAND THE
ACTIVITY IN OUR COMMUNITIES. I
THINK THAT YOU CAN TALK TO. THE
AUTHOR ABOUT IT PUTTING ON THE
CD YEAH I MEAN I SEE TO YOU
THEY WILL HAVE A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF INFORMATION AND I'M SURE
HE'S HAPPY TO DISCUSS WITH YOU
WHAT'S WHAT INFORMATION IS
PUSHED FORWARD AND WHAT'S NOT
AS LONG AS IT'S NOT. YOU KNOW
COMPLETELY DETAILED I THINK THE
PURPOSES FOR TO BE A
DISAGGREGATED INFORMATION BUT
EVEN WITH THAT YOU CAN GET WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING FOR WHICH IS
GENERAL LOCATION GENERAL AREA
MUCH TOP POSSIBLY AT AND I MEAN
THIS BILL SOLVING REAL PROBLEMS
IS THE FACILITATOR ISSUES REAL
AND- YEAH THAT'S THAT'S THE-
NUMBER. ONE YOU KNOW PART OF
THIS WHOLE TRIAGE THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH HERE THANK YOU FOR
STEP IN AND- COURSE THANK YOU-
RIGHT. SO MY QUESTION IS HELLO
OF CITY- AND- THE FUNDS. HAVE
EXPERTISE IN THIS NOW FOR THE
LAST YEAR. IN OUR CITY WE WERE
DEALING WITH THIS- WE USE WE'VE
ACTUALLY LANDED WITH A THIRD
PARTY FACILITATOR WHO DOES ALL
OF THE COLLECTION. FOR ALL OF
THAT INFORMATION. BECAUSE THIS
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE THAT CD TIERS
TRYING TO JUST BE THE-
FACILITATOR OF THE COLLECTING
OF CORRECT THE STUFF. THEY
DON'T THEY THEY'RE NOT GONNA GO
OUT THERE AND RESEARCHING GO
THROUGH CODE ENFORCEMENT DO ALL
THOSE THINGS TO FIND OUT WHO'S
RENTING WHO'S NOT. THEY'RE
GONNA BE USING COORDINATION
WITH THE PLATFORMS. AND
WHATEVER THE CITY'S MECHANISMS
ARE FOR OBTAINING INFORMATION
AND ONCE THEY HAVE THAT AND
THEN THEY CAN DO THEIR THING.
CORRECT CORRECT CORRECT ALL
RIGHT SO BECAUSE AND THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED TO SEPARATE IS
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO. FIRST
IS WHAT THE CITY'S
RESPONSIBILITY AS AN- MISTER
MISTER CORK HERE TALKING ABOUT
THAT EARLIER. IS YOU KNOW HOW
DO WE KNOW. WELL THE CITIES
HAVE TO TAKE A PROACTIVE ROLE
IN DOING THAT IF THEY WANT TO.
AND A AND I THINK THAT'S HOW
THEY WIND UP DOING THAT- THE
TOT TAX ARE ACTUALLY COLLECTED
ON A QUARTERLY BASIS- THE
OWNERS HAVE TO REPORT TO.
NINETY ASSESSOR NAY THEY DO
THAT THEY THEY WIND UP WRITING
A CHECK EVERY QUARTER FOR THAT.
EIGHT ZERO T. MY RECOLLECTION.
FROM MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES ALWAYS- ON. JUST A
GROSS NUMBERS RISE NUMBER BASED
UPON A ROOM OCCUPANCY NOT BASED
UPON. A TAXABLE INCOME AFTER
DEDUCTIONS DEPRECIATION ON OUR
NO IT'S JUST IT'S THE NUMBER OF
FLAT NUMBER FLAT NUMBER FROM
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE GOING FOR
FIFTY A NIGHT. GET YOUR TEA IS.
FIVE DOLLARS THAT'S RIGHT- SO
THEY WILL BE WORKING WITH THE-
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR NAY
CITY HIRES TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT INFORMATION TO COLLECT
THAT TAX. THERE'S NOTHING IN
THIS BILL THAT PREVENTS THEM
FROM DOING. WHAT JUST A
CURIOSITY BECAUSE- WHAT CITY
WAS THAT THAT THAT DO YOU HAVE-
DID THAT WITH YOU. WHAT'S WITH
CITY MARIANNA I'M HERE AT HOT
pYEAH. SO- SO ANYWAY SO THAT'S
WHY THAT AND THAT'S BASICALLY
THE IN THERE WAS ENSURING THAT
THEY WILL WITH THE FOR PARTY
AND THAT THE SOMEHOW CAME OUT
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW THAT GETS
CLEAN THAT'S RIGHT RIGHT THANK
YOU THIS ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WITH THAT I THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE TO DID A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF SEPARATING
WHAT THE ISSUES ARE THERE'S THE
ONE INFORMATION ISSUE ABOUT THE
INFORMATION INCLUDING WHETHER
PEOPLE SHOULD BE RENTING IN THE
SEPARATE INFORMATION IS ABOUT
THE COLLECTING OF THOSE TAXES
AND CREATING A SYSTEM. THAT
WILL HELP CITIES THAT HAVE NOT
CREATED THEIR OWN SYSTEM TO DO
IT WITH A LITTLE BIT MORE EASE
SO. WITH THAT. SENATOR WHICH-
WAS. YEAH I HAVE KIND OF A LONG
STATEMENT I WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU. ABOUT THIS MEASURE. AND
ABOUT THE- COMPETENCY IN THE
INTEGRITY OF THE AUTHOR. OF
THIS MEASURE. BUT I THINK
THAT'S A GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES I'LL PASS ON THAT
THE MANAGER AND MEMBERS AND-
SIMPLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
BEHALF CENTER MCGUIRE THANK YOU
SIR. WITH THAT MISS HIGHLANDER
WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL- WITH
THE FROM MY UNDERSTANDING THERE
WERE AMENDMENTS. OKAY GIVEN THE
MOTION AND MOTION BY MAY SECOND
BACK FOR. AND THIS TIME WE DO
THE MOTION IS. THE PAST TO
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY ON THE BILL
BURKE. BURKE I WHEN I GREAT.
GRAYSON GRAYSON I LEVINE LEVINE
AYE MAYES MAYES AYE MULLIN.
WELL AND I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS ARTWORK GROUP
FIVE REAVIS RIVAS I SERRA HI
THERE ARE A LOT. TEN ZERO IT'S
OUT THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING SO KIND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE NEED TO
DO ADELINE ST. IT'S A. RIGHT
READY FOR ADD ONS ON THE- ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR MULLIN.
MULLIN I RIVAS RIVERSIDE. ON SB
THREE OH THREE THAT BILL HAS
PASSED GRAY MULLIN MULLIN I
RIVAS RIVAS I. SB THREE NINE
FIVE THAT BILL HAS ALSO PASSED.
MULLIN MULLIN I RIVAS RIVAS I.
YOU ARE ALL CAUGHT UP. THANK
YOU RETIREMENT AND WELCOME BACK
WITH THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED.